spacex copies brace for splashdown after
more than
five months in space four astronauts on
board the dragon spacecraft splashed
down in the gulf of mexico
off the coast of florida
[Applause]
after a six and a half hour journey back
from the international space station
or iss they landed safely becoming the
first
crew to return from orbit in a spacex
mission
in partnership with nasa the nighttime
splashdown was nasa's first
since 1968 when apollo 8 the first
mission to send astronauts around the
moon
returned to earth i think this is a
remarkable achievement
the opportunity of a lifetime for many
of us
and something to be proud of americans
michael hopkins victor glover and
shannon walker
along with soichi naguchi of japan were
the four astronauts on board
this was glover's first time in space
he's also the first black nasa astronaut
to be a member of an iss crew after
medical checks they were taken ashore
and flown to houston texas today went
very well overall i would say almost
flawlessly
dragon did great you know it was great
to hear uh
the crew when they woke up the first
thing mike hopkins did it is ask
you know what's the weather going to be
like when we told him hey maybe
two knots of wind and one foot waves and
he was very excited from the very
beginning
the crew took off in november on board a
falcon 9 rocket
the mission is the first step in spacex
owner elon musk's plan to commercialize
space travel
continue to be nominal spacex
are looking to go straight to mars
without
without stopping elsewhere in in the
middle
nasa are looking at using the moon as a
test bet
in some ways this is baby steps uh on
that grand
that grand program that grand
development idea of
uh expanding human space flight once
again
but i think it's still a significant
step
while the astronauts recover the capsule
will be taken back to the launch site at
cape canaveral florida
and refurbished for another trip to
space
leah harding al jazeera